This
is Anna Clark for the Brooklyn public library on our street our stories project. I'm
here with some for you. It is May eighth two thousand and thirteen
and we're going to talk about his life and experiences in the neighborhood of
Williamsburg So I guess we should just start off with where were you
born born in Williamsburg actually first house I've lived in
was on twenty fourth through about when you then four shortly
thereafter I moved to I didn't move my parents moved me
actually to three thirty on Bedford Avenue where I spent most of
my growing up years went to school at St Peter's and Paul which is
a very straight and high school in Manhattan and power memorial.
But generally lived there until my parents moved back to Puerto Rico
in one thousand nine hundred ninety two.
As
best probably since about nineteen
forty something probably latter part of the big move
from two twenty four three thousand you probably came from the
edge of Bed Stuy. With the streets
around that opportunity
opportunity and a kind of slavery and he
said yes they are the first they came by
boat probably in the
late twenty's maybe early thirty's I would I would suspect the probably be the
late twenty's. Landed on Columbia Street which is now in the Red Hook section
very interesting place. I think it was a tiger and
the Odyssey but with the two boats that
might that it come together they met here but there was the two ships that
were applying the waters between Puerto Rico and New York at the
time to have any
particular early childhood memories.
Have lot to tell you that a lot. Well I
think
the Williams Very good to me growing up was
very familial very family
oriented place. We had a lot of kids I went to Catholic High grammar school
which couple blocks away so my
life really revolved around a three or four block area.
My friends playing basketball going to school with.
Even throughout high school we kept in touch and as we all scattered to different
schools some private schools like PA memorial St Francis Prep
or something along those lines or public schools like
Westinghouse my father was a lead a
I want to buy they go as we call them he had a little store
on south a street between Bedford and Berry. And.
You know that played a big life part of my life tallying between Southard se
brink bringing him his
dinner working in the store and Saturdays helping
him you know moving goods or delivering food we used
to at that time used to deliver groceries of theirs to the six story
walkup It's like the Fresh Direct back in the scene at fifty five you
know. It. You know just just living in a neighborhood it was.
At that time was somewhat mixed more mixed and it wasn't as I got older.
There was still a healthy representation of Jews
Polish
Irish so and. During my time in my early
years when I took you know five eight nine ten years
old then as I got a little
older those folks started moving in.
And they were you know the parents are getting older. The kids are starting to move out that
it became really a bad Hispanic
community predominantly Puerto
Rican some blacks not many that would
have been other other parts of the
neighborhood in the sixty's a lot of gangs predominantly
the young not the Lord and the help burn as those are two two big
things that operate in the community and it. It was you know zip
guns and you know gang fights very sort of West Side Story
which is very clannish we never
walked into the left side of the snow side. Very town
and in between there was one
school that closed pretty early but it was a small Polish community.
You know in fact one of the guys used to hang out with us and his teddy type you know.
In that block which was very that was right across from the
church south of second between Barry and white the
very solid
Polish community or block and you know as time went on that that sort
of disappeared as well. My
mom was a homemaker for many years but then she got a job working for the Board of
Education as a cook she was the head cook for a school
in I think was that Diane St Mark's when
you say Mark's Place right and the
children's music. So she's do
that here
in the building
where my father had his store had
huge huge coal boilers coal called Fire boilers
and what we used to do was take the potatoes
from my father's potato den and then go into during the wintertime
going into the boiler room putting. The potatoes on a
stick and cooking them over a cup of the cold hard
calls these are big boilers sevens like you know those of like
a lot of the things we used to do was and obviously it
was you know. It was just the people that were there these to come in every day and
sometimes they standing on the counter and help my dad you know make me feel like I was a
businessman and you know and being with my father was a lot of and
so when it was
about basketball and baseball
and basketball and baseball really you know city sports.
My my daughter who who was working for a
an advertising firm in Portland
the firm handled the Nike account.
And they also handled the converse nigger's
account of that and this is
really so I got a pair of Converse knickers from my
daughter the other day and I put them on for the first time in like forty
years and I cannot believe how hard
they were.
Saying this because wouldn't growing up we used to buy our converse knickers
on the corner of roving and have them are this Army Navy store twelve
dollars for irregulars the used to burn into the
bottom are and it could've been that the little line was crooked so they put him as a regular by
them and I spent my entire day playing basketball in
the sneakers and I put him on forty years late and I could walk and then
they did so hard so we you know we spent a lot of time playing basketball.
I happen to had some skills have some skills and in swimming so I sort
of branched out a
little. So I did I went to the neighborhood Y. over there
because my parents. They were probably lower middle
class a little bit more disposable income and that's where used to go after
school. And I learned how to swim there. I got my license to be
a lifeguard and that helped me become a lifeguard in Coney Island so I
were the beach for a number of years as a lifeguard this great of the
same cast
of twenty nine inch
waist is wonderful how do you describe
your neighborhood.
Well you know growing up in in
the segments let's call it from birth to
about fifteen sixteen. It
was not a very bad place to live and it was pretty
cool you know we know everybody a lot of the people who are around there you know we were tight groups of
friends and we played basketball as
a side and baseball we did sports and whatever we can get our hands on
later on as the neighborhood began to change dramatically.
It is war
as we became for socially conscious.
And seeing you know a little bit more poverty in the neighborhood a little more
crime drugs then it became a very very different neighborhood when I
was growing up because I could have been just totally not aware of it.
You know being younger and as I got older. I just became more and more aware of it but the
gangs in the early years weren't into drugs as much as they were in the sixty's with
heroin started pouring into the communities and stuff like that started claiming a lot of lives.
So we the
group that I hung out with the most we we were
very much attached to the church. Big big influence
in our lives Catholic Charities which is a. Organization in Brooklyn had put
in a lot
of time and energy and money into afterschool centers
and in social workers to work with the kids group work and stuff like
that and they did it in three different predominantly three
different churches
epiphany chance figuration and Peter in part
so the Association for a lot of us was what church which is
what your parish and even boards when you start going to different label Jesus
identify it have been Reggie's to call St Anselm C.S.
because ph and stuff like that but we did a lot of
stuff when spared. Around social clubs. So we are
you know so we sort of tend to
self identify with groups and his cause sells Christian names like the deacons of
testimony and. The Christians and stuff like
that and we. And it's by age group so the Christian to a folder or
universe along is a little younger I belong to the deacons stuff like that
and they were it was very
much friendly with very different communities like through
the church you know through penny always parent with us that was
totally different community. And you know we did a lot of sports together we
played softball against them and we check neighbor
championships and the thing is that the
church saved a lot of folks. Through these
programs
lost a lot but we saved them on
and it was a time that a lot of the priest and the nuns were into
social change and social activism and a lot of us got involved
in in doing. You know community work in many many different
forms later on I got involved in housing movement in students.
I started as the deputy director then became director and a lot of us
still keep together. I mean you know I'm still friendly little lot of the some of the
guys and gals that I grew up with you know since first grade in grammar school. So you know it's
very very very
tight to
find
my cultural or just particular family
where
my
I came from a very My parents came from very large
humungous family. I was doing sort of like a
to search the other day on
the fact my father's family's.
Web page and I never really counted it but my father had eighteen brothers
and
sisters. And my mother's side we had from
the second wife. Fifteen brothers and sisters and I'm
not quite sure how many from the first wife but I'm sure it
was in double digits. So I have about one hundred first
cousins at least at least.
But the ones that I really knew were the ones on my mother's side and a lot
of them came all the while they were like fourteen. You
know the most intimate twelve girls and three men on my
mother's side a good many of the women came none of the men
came to and I still haven't figured that one out. But.
So
we had about at some point maybe eight or ten of my mother's
sisters all around Williamsburg and and also
in Bed Stuy in Brownsville and places like that and moved on
to Bushwick and. All the places which are really have now called the
and it
was
a really really really close family so the traditions for the traditions of
Easter traditions of getting together to New Year's Christmas and you
know tradition of just dropping in and on and on your cousins
and your aunts and uncles houses and stuff like
that my mother because my father worked a lot of hours at the
store and my mother worked you know five days during the week she liked to go
out love to go out
and most times somebody the store the other day
and it's almost like a tradition for her anyway and my
family my mother would say let's go to visit somebody like my
D.D. globally and she lived in grapes and back
then and my father said call first to see if she's
home and my mother would say
no because if she wasn't home they wouldn't go anywhere. So my
mother would say let's get in the car. Let's take the ride and we'll knock on the door.
And she said if they're not home. We had a nice run. But that's the way
it was
I mean the thing is it's a tradition in Puerto Rico's I don't know if it's still but even you know
last time I was there you just sort of like show up and all of a sudden you're
Fadden you're you know you visit another family just show up and
that's the way it was over here in New York and it's not you know this is still just a nice
little way you lived the way you were you treated with you know
by family and the openness and there's a tradition that you know you just did
it
so
my mother was was a little bit eclectic in her cooking she was
an incredible cup. I mean she had all the. All the Puerto Rican Staples she did
very well but she branched out a lot you know and I don't mean that she was like
a you know I'm a cook or anything like
that but even to go into the Italian food or eat you know she'd things like that that was
different from a lot of other folks in the neighborhood would have cooked and not a
little departure from Puerto Rican cooking. So you know I was introduced to different types of food
but Puerto Rican food that was that was a specialty especially in
she when she
was working at the school as a cook.
It just so happened that one of the dieticians
for that area happened to be my mother's niece.
So what they would do was they would
experiment cooking for an
entire grammar
school using you know ethnic foods with they had no you know they
had no real recipes. They didn't say like two teaspoons or you know what I mean
it's so cute imagine cooking for six seven hundred kids and creating
these recipes for those you know for the food and stuff
like that she was good because of that but she never
taught me how to cook. You
know it's one of those cooks that said yes that's how much he put it he's
he's a little one to dealing you know which means just a little bit you know.
What just collect that throw it in. And you know never say qualities to have these
from tables and just do it and you know and
if she had what we call it a lot you did a lot of putting families will tell you that they have the magic pot.
They have this one pot on the stove that they can have ten people show
up and out of that one pot create a dinner for for
ten people. It was just you know like the miracle of the. And fishes you know fish in
those it was
just
incredible
to me about everything that.
Well it started quite frankly again with the church. I mean the thing you
said one of the things that we used to
do during Thanksgiving was there was a lot
of food donated and turkeys and you
know can foods and stuff like that we used to
do as a group my
friends through the church. We used to deliver
those food to a lot of the
the family support families in the community. Given
my vast experience of walking up six flights for my father you know stores delivering food has
pretty good at it.
But then you know the sixty's came around and it was you know the you know
more and it was it was you know the fight to
do elections and get people that we
had we you know we met friends and folks from different parts of
Leesburg that were working towards changing the elected officials and stuff
like that so he started getting involved like
that
we worked on the first second Lindsay campaign campaign to
oust Gerard Rooney who was you know very
very conservative legislator there. We worked on the our
lives teen It was a really I'm a very progressive guy
who was running for Congress Delany's campaign so we just you know we sort
of organizing you know a political campaign to
working with campaigns and as you go through that you start all of a sudden beginning
more aware of some of the major problems of the neighborhood you know housing being one of them.
The bigger one who is a time to have. People were really beginning to walk away
from landlords walking away from their their responsibilities in housing.
And you had developers are coming into being what they call
got rehabilitation of buildings displacing you know all of the tenants and those tenants will
never come
back so you know stuff that you were doing organizing politically was
being broken down by those types of actions and those type of things
there was no voice in the community in terms of programs and elected
officials and stuff like that so all of a sudden you know people started getting
involved
and once again you know getting involved in you know when you look lose
the predecessor to live service with this group called New Age
realty bunch of idealistic guys and gals who felt that you
know if you were diligent. You could run
housing and through the red rose you can manage it and get it done.
They they would quickly dissolution and they found the the the red world did not have enough money in it
to buy the oil to make the
repairs and they started experiencing some of the issues that a lot of the lenses
were experience in the community and they then turned around and
through the
city programs began another group
called lawsuit S.. And they organized it was really to because the guys who
were involved were
from you know the thing guys from Chance figuration the same guys
from Peter and Paul saying guys from the fifty's that we all know.
The chance guys as we call them they had a very couple of very very
activist priest there you know Brian Cabell is I don't know people heard his name is John Mulhern. You
know these guys were like.
Incredible. They were much more politically active that we
were in some of them a little bit older but their
influence in our relationship. Sort of brought us along seeing work together
the stuff.
So
your work
need
a moment here that you are hearing
that the proudest
moments the proudest moments just to see
and help and save a couple of buildings in doing ten organizing
you know I did I also did all the maintenance part of it as a supervisor a lot of the
operational rent collections and stuff like
that some policy work mainly but mainly running the business from that
point to
be working with
these buildings stabilizing them and
building but and maintaining a community and that
was like incredible to have that type of influence
and you know using the programs in
the city for the best and for the benefit of a lot of folks who are who
were called personally because
people you know guy got on the board of this was
was his name was done for none dough. He lives on sub second Street to twenty five
to two to twenty so it's first
rate and he he worked as
a assembler Fedders air conditioning.
You know and all of a sudden you know he probably had if maybe an eighth grade education. Well
the Son The sitting on the board of the organization
and running a company. I mean it's
it's developing you know real leadership within the community.
Running
a corporate and bringing people along.
It's a it's a real education process going into the
building and talking to folks and trying to have them get to get organized in order
to control their living space in the
building working together to to a common goal. It takes a lot of time and
a lot of trust a lot of energy and people have different motives and you know not
everybody is you know people
sometimes leave me alone I just want to get up in the morning go to
work come home turn on T.V. and watch a baseball game.
And you know sometimes you've got to get everybody involved in sort of
stuff and it's that that's really aren't really hard to do providing a
creative vision for them it's
not it's not easy if you live in
and day.
Well it did happen I mean I did move away
and go away. It it
didn't stop my commitment to the
neighborhood at that time in my life.
It was important it was just important because a thing is that this was where I grew up in this is
was what I loved. I mean you know it was it
was where a lot of my friends were and people whom I knew the parents
of my friends.
So it was something that you know you had you just felt that you had to do something to get back.
But then you know things changed. You know in. I
was in Lee started college in one thousand nine hundred sixty seven and I
went on for three years and it was probably the most.
You know during school was very active in a lot of different
things still in that community and you know was always a movement always
campaign always something going on so I left and then I started working
for Catholic Charities as a group worker. You know what goes around comes around
you know that I was approached to become
the deputy director and I went on to do
that big time a lot of this to work is coming in and
helping to you know a lot of the stuff
as as young as I was and sometimes younger.
They had graduated from college and sort of stuff and I was looking at this whole situation they said you
know maybe I should go back to school so after a period of time I thought it was
in my best interest.
And at that point also the best interests of the community they go
off to college to return to college and finish my my
my college education and that's what I did and I wound up.
Williams College and northwest corner Massachusetts in the purple
Valley political science.
Well then I went to
Yale graduated. WILLIAMS When C.E.O. went to the school the
organization manager did not finish.
There came back went to work in
Washington as a legislative director for Congressman in the South Bronx got involved in
the South Bronx handled all of his housing
legislation banking and he says he sat on the housing banking and everyone fares Committee and he did
a lot of the work on that area and then I
went left him after a few years and were doing the South
Bronx rehabilitation. You know the whole commitment by Carter and
Reagan to do something but the sub. Did a lot of the work. Planning on the housing side.
So that
well I really never left New York. I
mean you know I mean New Jersey now that's something that's the sad part of the dream things
have but you know
I after I went to college I went
to Williams So obviously and then I went to Yale.
Then I came back to New York for a very short period of time and then I went to Washington for
for a couple years but I was doing the back and forth from New York to Washington because of
the some of the constituency work in the to be done and also some of the you know the
policy stuff that had to be done then
I stayed in New
York when I worked for the South Bronx development office and then I
worked for. Sesame
Street assistant the president for by legal affairs.
I
worked for Star and housing as a direct of community relations
work for St Luke's Roosevelt Hospital handling their housing stuff.
Then I went to work for fifty houses doing their housing stuff in
the small not for profit over here called the
door central tenet of his which is on room and board
and six that I knew and then I got to the Port Authority. So I've been with them
for twenty some odd years now.
And a tenor and all over the place very different sort
of
work you know. Do you have any opinion
on the changes and that's the
only guy you
know I had I had lunch.
I had lunch with a bunch of friends from the
Lasorda stays you know the attorney who worked for. The actual legal services
who's basically one of the
the found not the founders but the catalyst to this was heading to
the near front of our minds that we maintain a relationship. For forty some
odd years who was the director when I
was there will be Vargas. And if you come across
him whom I've known
forever and in we sat there
talking about that same issue feeling about Linspire and how it's evolved and how
it's
changed how these pieces of real estate like for instance
my parents bought that house nine hundred fifty for about thirty of that for having used
three family houses retail for seventeen thousand
dollars and in one thousand nine hundred
seventy two because of the redlining mortgage real
want Lee mortgage redlining where the banks would literally
jor red line around the map and say we will not
land within that red line. So that's how the term came out to be redlining.
So my parents sold the house in one thousand nine hundred seventy two.
Could not get a mortgage the people could not get a mortgage to get what they call the purchase money mortgage
and he sold it to seventeen thousand five hundred dollars.
He still remember mother's hand says at least I was able to pay the bills. So
we lived there for a long time twenty to twenty some odd
years the House today is probably worth
about four million dollars.
The change is a tremendous And you know in any gentrified neighborhood you have that type
of pressure you have that type of you know financial incentives
and for people you know to leave the school the
leave the area and stuff like that. And you
know. Why shouldn't those who live there for twenty
years that are retiring now have an opportunity
to pull in enormous amount of equity to go somewhere else where they really want
to be whether it's going to be for
Lando Florida back to Puerto Rico. You know or wherever and have a
really great nest egg but the cost of that is
enormous hugely enormous simply that
you know. Years that people have
invested in
maintaining affordable housing maintaining
community doing to organize organizational work all of a sudden
just disappears. It's rough. It's rough you know
the division
of of water communicant be like of sudden gets wiped away
twenty years of work just down the train more or less for what to
become
become what you know become like the hipster place.
You know where very few people can afford to live. So
it's with mixed emotion. You
know did we do a good job. Do we do it in quite incredible job.
I don't
know I look at it from the point of view of you know if it
were my father and mother retiring
in the one nine hundred seventy two and they're able to pull three four million dollars out of
out of the the building that they they maintained and you
know all that sort of stuff and Raible to go back to Puerto Rico and
not worry about money and scrape you know scrape and even their retirement they had no pension.
You know. And no pension or my parents live on their Social Security which is not very
much they had a great life pale in their own house everything but it wasn't it
wasn't you know anything phenomenal.
But they were happy I mean that's the important thing you know this matter if they had. Well they had a hundred
thousand miles they were happy you know.
So
anything else like that
cater
to people.
Well situated because the thing is I was down there not very long ago
and and I'm not quite sure quite sure if I could never go back.
Let me rephrase that I can never afford to go back.
But even if I had the money to go back. I don't think I would
want to go back. It's changed much to my just now but you know it's not the type
of neighborhood that such was my memories it's not the type of neighborhood
rather I'd want to be
and I don't think
anything you think about it's just
not my type of neighborhood means
my kids type of neighborhood.
I find it amusing that my kids invite me to dinner.
And I look at the stores is all that was King Charles and that was the Armenian and now I see
him you know who placed food that's not that's different and stuff like
that the apartment to their living room apartment is where
we're you know in the one nine hundred seventy S. we were demonstrating against
the against
the developers you know her high Kraus and stuff like that and now you know my
daughter's sort of living there you know for a period of
time and not knowing any of the history here and in even if I explained that
she wouldn't
understand
you know much here.
You're quite welcome and thank you for coming over here from the wilds of
Brooklyn.